countdown world premiere of in the
morning
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
two one jlo turned the world premiere
of her new single in the morning into
a family affair
[Music]
the living room transformed into a dance
floor
as the singer celebrated her new jam
alongside her twins
emmy and max her fiance alex rodriguez
and his daughters ella and natasha
[Music]
jlo shared the lively instagram video on
saturday
and captioned the post quote our little
in the morning virtual dance party
was fire i hope everyone had a wonderful
weekend
coconuts hashtag jlo in the morning
my life right now is just so amazing
uh my personal life you know my kids
everything everything is just in a great
place and i feel
really lucky jennifer teased the see me
single earlier this week
by posting the cover art to instagram
which features her
fully nude she captioned the post with
multiple hashtags
including in the morning morning face
turkey egg and
new music i don't ever want to lose that
sense of
excitement about what i do or that
inspiration to ever leave me
to want to do more to want to do
different things j-rod got engaged in
2019.
and planned to marry this year but it
was postponed
due to the pandemic how's the wedding
planning going it's going
good it's going good i think you know we
know we have a pretty busy year ahead of
us so
yeah you know we we are gonna take your
time
yeah i think you know there's no rush
children we really
see this as something that is gonna be
forever and we're gonna
we're gonna just take our time and and
and do it right
for now jennifer is getting back to work
just last week the 51 year old
hit the stage with maluma at the amas
the two latin singers who co-star in the
upcoming rom-com
marry me gave a sultry performance to
their hit songs
potty and lonely i'm sorry
[Music]
sexy hits and moves have inspired many
but it hasn't gone without criticism
here's what she told et
about people who try to put her in a box
because she's a mom
and because of her age i refuse to be
put in a box in that way do you know
what i mean why because i'm
over 40 so i can't be sexy or is it
because i'm a mom
moms aren't allowed to be sexy how did i
get my kids in the first place
you know for me it's like
what is the criteria for when you
do or don't do something do you know
what i mean
you